(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] They're-
They're very excited, Jo.
- I love it.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
You should feel good about yourself.
- Aww
- [Kelly] That rarely happens.
- Thank you.
- Nicely done.
It was probably the denim.
- [Jo] It's the denim.
- Yeah. Yeah.
(both chuckle)
- So wait, last time,
last time you were here
was with Chelsea.
- [Jo] Yes.
- I love this.
Y'all aren't together anymore,
but you're still friends.
- Oh, yeah.
- [Kelly] I think that's amazing.
That's hard to do sometimes.
- Oh, yeah.
I mean, it's not that hard.
I mean,
- Okay, well for others.
- Yeah. Well, yeah.
(both chuckle)
- So for others, it might be.
- But, you know,
it's just,
especially when you have a kid,
I have a son,
you know what I mean?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And when you go through a breakup,
you wanna be a role model as well, right?
- Yeah.
- You lead by example.
You don't want him to do that.
- Yeah.
- So, like,
his mommy,
it's like we're best friends.
To this day, we're best friends.
- [Kelly] I remember you
telling me that. Yeah.
- Yeah. She lives right in front of me.
I have a house right in front of me,
and that's where she lives.
- That's awesome.
- Yeah. She's got all the keys to my cars,
the codes and everything.
And like, when I'm on the road, like,
I don't have to worry about anything.
- That's like incredibly healthy.
- Yes. It's so healthy.
- Yeah.
- And it can work.
You guys were friends before.
You can be friends after.
- I know. I think so.
- Yes
- Okay. I agree. I agree.
- [Jo] Yeah.
- Well, speaking of good relationships,
so you and your son,
y'all were just in Dubai together?
- Yes.
- What'd you, I've never been to Dubai.
- [Jo] You have to go.
- [Kelly] I've never been. Yeah.
- [Jo] I was at Coca-Cola Arena.
It was massive.
Everyone was there,
and you can do anything in Dubai.
So, anything!
I saw a penguin for the first time.
- You mean one of the big, huge ones?
- No. I saw a penguin.
Like,
you're supposed to go to Antarctica,
but in Dubai, they're like,
oh, we can bring that here.
(Kelly laughs)
- I've never seen a zebra.
- Penguins? We have 20 of them right here.
(both laugh)
Dubai has everything.
I was skiing in Dubai.
I was like, I bought shoes at Foot Locker,
I was like, I feel like going skiing.
And then we went skiing.
- Oh my gosh!
- You're skiing inside the mall,
and then we pet penguins.
- You just literally like,
did your feet and everything.
- Oh my God.
My son was snowboarding, I'm like,
this is crazy, right, son?
- That's awesome!
I prefer snowboarding over skiing, too.
Well, I prefer none of that now.
It's, nope.
- No.
- But wait,
did you see the tallest
building in the world?
That's there, right?
- Yeah, Burj Khalifa.
- Oh, okay.
- Burj Khalifa.
- I don't know if you guys know that,
but Burj Khalifa is a a skyscraper
on top of another skyscraper.
Oh, there it is.
Look at this thing.
- That would worry me
to be in that building.
I don't know why.
- Yeah, the minute you get to the top,
you go, I want to go down.
(audience laughs)
- [Kelly] Yeah. I'm not
even afraid of heights.
- Yeah.
- I just don't know.
It just sticks-
I don't like to stand out like that.
- Mm
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah.
- No, you wouldn't wanna
be on top of that thing.
- [Kelly] Nope.
- Yeah. I wanted to go down.
I don't like heights.
- Oh.
- So, when you look down
and you see a skyscraper below you,
you're like, okay, yeah, this is too high.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- This is too high.
- I'm not afraid of heights.
It's just,
I feel like you're a target.
I don't know. It just feels like a target.
- A target?
Kelly, What is going on?
- Look.
- [Jo] Like you're a target of what?
- I am in a Jason Bourne film right now.
(all laugh)
Like, look,
I'm the girl that comes in the restaurant,
I'm like, where are the exit signs?
- I'm that way too!
- Look, you don't know!
(Jo yells)
You don't know.
- Why do you think I
keep looking behind me.
- I know. I know.
I'm about to scare the crap outta you.
I'm just kidding.
- So, when you go to a restaurant,
like, you have to have a
wall behind you, right?
- I do prefer that.
I don't have to.
As long as, like, a loved one can see
and give me a heads up.
- Ah, I got you.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Like, yeah, like watch out, Kelly.
- I'm just saying, like,
you know, the news is crazy.
You just don't know.
- Yeah.
- I like to, I like to have,
- You never know what
pops off at Olive Garden.
- Yeah. I'm just like, oh,
but some really good
salad and bread sticks.
You do know that.
Wait,
it's great though that you
took a tour with your son, right?
- [Jo] Yes.
- He went on tour with you?
- He goes on tour with me.
He works for me.
He's actually the best employee.
He's incredible.
- [Kelly] Oh, are you hard
on him or easier on him?
- No, I'm easy,
'cause he works hard.
It's really cool.
And we only pay him in Sour Patch Kids.
(Kelly laughs)
It's so easy.
(audience applauds)
- It's awesome.
Free labor.
- Yeah. It's like Takis and Sour Patch.
He's like, okay.
I guess I will stay over time, dad.
(Kelly laughs)
- So wait,
your Netflix special was shot here,
- Yes.
- In LA.
And it's called Live from
the Los Angeles Forum.
- Come on.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- You played it, right?
- I have played the Forum, yeah.
- I'm the first comic to
ever do it four times.
What?
(audience cheers)
- Sold out. Sold out four times.
- Four times? Like,
- Sold it out four times.
(audience cheers)
There you go.
- [Kelly] Wow.
(audience applauds)
- You know, this is my
fourth time on this show.
Give me my jacket.
- Oh, we haven't one that yet.
- Yeah. Gimme my jacket.
(Kelly laughs)
I want my jacket.
- We will get you a jacket.
(Jo screams)
- Yes!
Yes!
- You wanna grab it?
- Yes!
(audience cheering)
Yes!
- [Kelly] Exactly. Exactly.
- [Jo] Yes!
- Exactly.
You look good in purple!
- This is my color.
- This is your color?
- Oh, I love it!
- We don't do this anymore.
You're special.
(audience cheering)
You have to love me now.
- She says,
She says that they don't do this anymore,
and I'm very special.